pour nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
elle a effectivement parlé aussi
présente bien sûr je pense que ce
qu'elle voulait dire surtout c'est que
c'était salutaire dans le sens où la
parole se libère lutte et ça veut dire
ça veut dire que comme le disait andré
bercoff à l'instant il ya une omerta et
qu'il est grand temps que la parole se
libère un peu plus et que et que que la
perspective se retourne si vous voulez
puisqu'on dit enfin selon les enquêtes
malgré tout que c'est à peu près une
femme sur cinq qui dans le courant de sa
vie professionnelle est l'objet
d'harcèlement c'est énorme
c'était énorme donc oui moi je trouve
que c'est salutaire et je suis je
partage sans barguigner ce point de vue
maintenant il ya un autre sujet dans le
sujet et on les vocal à 106 est question
de la de redire de la délation ou de la
diffamation de ces risques là alors moi
je vais avancé une autre explication à
l'attitude de bruno le maire peut-être
qu'effectivement c'est une
caractéristique du monomère mais au-delà
de ça je pense que ça dit quelque chose
d'un peu plus profond sur la société
française
je pense qu'on a je dis ça parce que je
le dise at du duo de mon expérience
britannique d'avoir vécu plusieurs
années à la société britannique a un
rapport très différent cette chose là je
la société française est très marqué sur
ces questions-là de ces mots c'est mon
analyse par la période de vichy par le
fait que dès l'instant où vous dites
vous montrer quelqu'un du doigt c'est
perçu comme collabos donc quand goût
délation quand encore boa vista on a une
relation à sa qui est là où
al'inverse les britanniques et le name
and shame nommer mais et parce que la
culture vous avez raison mais c'est
aussi la culture protestante
je veux juste un élément d occasion vous
appelez les britanniques voient ça comme
un acte de citoyenneté
quand il vous explique soeur et vous
vous écartez les yeux dans l'eau et vous
dites mais comment ça de la citoyenneté
de montrer le voisin mais absolument
monsieur si je vois que son voisin est
en train de frapper son enfant je dois
le dénoncer c'est un acte ses citoyens
de solidarité avec la société et ses
valeurs nous on a un rapport à ça qui
est extrêmement différent je pense que
l'épisode lemaire quelque part et nous
sorte d'avatar de ceux de ce mal dans
cette relation tous